we're learning more about the potential
ability of hospitals to handle the
growing number of coronavirus patients a
new ProPublica analysis of data from the
Harvard Global Health Institute shows
which parts of the country could run out
of available hospital beds and a winner
joins us from San Francisco to break
down the numbers and a bay area
residents are being told to stay home
yep that's correct and moves like this
shelter in place order where basically
you can be in your home you can go to
essential stores groceries and
pharmacies and a couple others but
that's it otherwise they're being told
to stay home those moves are key because
otherwise hospitals may face becoming
overloaded with life-and-death
consequences at Long Island's Good
Samaritan Hospital Medical Center
workers are setting up tents to test
people for coronavirus this large
Hospital has 437 beds
64 in the intensive care unit on any
given day eighty to eighty-five percent
of those ICU beds are full limiting
capacity for any influx of coronavirus
patients but administrators say they're
now getting ready for the worst-case
scenario
Patrick o Shaughnessy is the executive
vice president of Catholic health
services which runs Good Samaritan some
of the things that we are working on and
doing or limiting perhaps less severe
acute interventions within the hospitals
right so things that could be done on an
elective basis perhaps are going to be
delayed or cancelled to free up capacity
this is going to be more of a marathon
and not a sprint but hospitals in some
areas of the country are likely to be
under more pressure than others
ProPublica created maps using new data
from the Harvard Global Health Institute
that shows what happens if the virus
spreads more quickly or more slowly in
what researchers call the best case
scenario where 20% of adults are
infected with coronavirus over a span of
18 months the map shows hospitals can
largely accommodate the influx but
ProPublica reports even then beds would
be 95 percent full but now look at the
path for the worst-case scenarios first
with 20% of adults becoming infected
over six months at that rate hospitals
in the red regions quickly need many
more beds than they actually have
then if 60% of adults get coronavirus in
a six-month time span the map turns
virtually all red meaning the US would
need more than 7 times the number of
available hospital beds than it
currently has what it shows says the
Harvard Institute's director dr. Ashish
Jha the data says that if we fail to act
if we go with the status quo we are
going to be in a lot of trouble that
most hospitals in most communities are
going to end up getting overwhelmed for
hospitals he says that means freeing up
beds for communities it's about
continuing to shut down public venues
including restaurants and bars this is a
national emergency where we're all going
to have to work together
every mayor every governor has to be
asking themselves are they gonna be part
of the solution or they can be part of
the problem
Charles Ornstein is deputy managing
editor for ProPublica when you look at
this data
the one thing that becomes crystal clear
is that it is essential that we slow
down this pandemic and that we try to
stretch it out over as long a period as
possible a major goal he says to avoid a
situation similar to Italy's where
doctors in the worst-hit regions are
reported to have received guidance to
only treat patients deemed worthy of
intensive care doctors and hospitals are
going to be forced to make decisions
they didn't go into medicine for and
essentially that's going to be
relegating some patients to death now
the researchers and writers here point
out that this information these models
are based on current information of
course that can change another point
from the researchers is that large metro
areas and big cities like here in the
Bay Area are really going to have to
work hard to clear out bed space rural
areas face a major challenge with some
of this with reduced intensive care unit
beds now the governor of Ohio issued an
order yesterday postponing elective
surgeries and procedures for hospitals -
in an effort to reserve beds for the
critically ill patients that they
anticipate will be coming in Tony
yeah and that really crystallizes the
need to take these precautions seriously
and shelter in place if that's the order
in your community reduce the large
gatherings you're in San Francisco where
they have that shelter in place order RP
taking it seriously I think they really
are you know you're seeing people talk
about the highways and the freeways here
being empty of traffic there are some
stories people are allowed to go to
groceries and pharmacies but they
basically closed down businesses here so
even if you wanted to go into work you
really can't in most cases and so we
think that people are taking it
seriously and hopefully they'll continue
to do that yeah where are you Anna it's
a very pretty kitchen so I am at I'm in
Berkeley California which is actually
across the bay from San Francisco Cales
okay I guess you don't want me to know
where you are I'm in Gail is a great
clean refrigerator that's what I thought
okay thank you very much we appreciate
it